all right it is a sport everyone from
grandma to grandma's friends your cool
cousin
they're all trying it's pickleball
the plaza hotel now holding a four-day
clinic that's how long it'll take you to
get your mason now ready to go for your
pickleball tournaments candace charles
live this morning with some of the
health benefits of the sport and just
why it's so darn cool candace good
morning to you
good morning to you john you make it
sound even more cool when you say it
like that for sure it's one of the
fasting growing sports we've heard of
folks are getting in from every
direction and pickleball courts are
really popping up all over the place but
we are the plaza has the most pickleball
sports courts all throughout las vegas
and i'm joined by steve cole who will be
leading the clinics this week you got to
tell me why are so many people getting
in on this sport well actually it's very
easy to learn our sport it's a low
impact sport so anybody can play it okay
okay so anybody including me so we're
gonna give it a try here i've got darla
christensen she's also a professional
player and she's gonna show me how to do
a little bit of serving so what do we
start with i wish i was a professional
player there you go
i'm actually an instructor so i love it
so we're going to learn how to serve so
the key thing with the service it must
be upward okay okay
you must strike the ball below your
waist okay and then from there it's just
doing it do you want steve to hold the
mic okay let's see if i give a try hand
over my mic guys can you believe that
okay there you go all right so we're
just going to have the ball
and now serving candace charles at 40
and there you go it's not just fashion
job it's definitely technique and you
guys can try yourself the clinic is
going to be on thursday and saturday
thursday at 5 00 8 am on saturday and of
course i got you covered with all the
details at 8newsnow.com guys candace is
like this brushing up shoulders
yeah pickleball easy game done
thanks